.
>> Members of congress and
distinguished guests, welcome to
the
Library of Congress and
the 8th Kissinger Lecture.  The
Kissinger program is made
possible
by generous donations and
admirers of Dr. Kissinger who
was the 56th secretary of state
of the United States and a
recipient o of the Nobel Peace
Prize.  Before we move on, we
join America in
mourning the passing of former
president George HWBusH.
The Kissinger program
celebrates statesmanship and
foreign policy.  This is in
keeping with exactly that
tradition.  We all wish the
extended Bush family
and has many close friends the
best in this difficult time.
We mourn the passing also last
month of Dr.
James billing  ger.
His distinguished career here at
the library spanned 2 years.
The Kissinger Lecture has been
delivered
by heads of state, including
Tony Blair,
and former president of Brazil,
former president of the French
republic, as
well as former United States
secretaries of state.
We will have an address by our
Kissinger lecturer, madam
Christine Lagarde,
followed by a conversation with
Margaret
Brennan, CBS News correspondent
and host of Face the Nation.
I now introduce Dr.
Carla Hayden, the 14th Librarian
of Congress.
[Applause]
>> CARLA HAYDEN: Good evening,
madam
Lagarde, members of congress,
and distinguished guests.  We
are deeply honored to welcome to
the Library of Congress tonight
Christine Lagarde, managing
director of the international
monetary fund.
As you can see, we are in the
great
hall, of the library's
Thomas Jefferson building,
surrounded
by visual art, symbolizing the
progress of civilization and the
traditions of
knowledge and learning, a most
fitting
venue for the 8th Kissinger
Lecture.
Christine Lagarde is a
distinguished public servant
with a deep knowledge on of the
world economy and the ways
financial architecture can shape
the lives of individuals in
countries around the globe.
Among her many high ranking
appointments in the private and
public sector, in June she
became the first woman to hold
the post of finance and economy
minister
of a G7 country, later as
chairman of
the G20 she set in motion a wide
ranging agenda.
She later became the 11th
managing director of the IMF and
the first woman to hold that
position.
On February 19, 2016, the IMF
executive board selected her to
serve as the managing director
for a second five-year term.
She has tackled some of the most
challenging financial issues
related to European integration,
international
trade, and the development of
global economic governance.
However, I am excited to be the
person
that will deliver breaking news.
The room just got a little
quieter.
Well, today Forbes released its
100 Most Powerful Women in the
World.
And  Madam Christine Lagarde was
voted the third most powerful
woman in the world.
[Applause]
[Cheers]
>> CARLA HAYDEN: So, ladies and
gentlemen, please join me in
welcoming Ms. Christine Lagarde.
[Applause]
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: Thank you
very much, Dr.
Hayden, dear Carla, for this
generous and brief introduction.
They are the best.  They are the
best.
I'm so happy to see many of you
here, my friends, and very much
looking forward to the
discussion that we will
have after these remarks with
Margaret Brennan.  Thank you
also, Mr.
Haskil, for the warm welcome you
extended to all of us.
He could not be here tonight but
I had a conversation with him
just before
arriving at this beautiful
Library of Congress.
And Henry Kissinger was
delighted that we were gathering
tonight and he has
asked me to express to all of
you his best wishes and very
strong support for continuing
the lecture that he started back
in 2001.
I would also like to indicate
myself that somebody else is
very much in our thoughts
tonight, and that is obviously
former  President George H.W.
Bush is all his family members.
We all mourn his passing.  Many
others are trying to enter into
the rotunda as we speak.
And we celebrate the arc of his
life.
The pilot who bravely fought in
World
War II, the president who helped
heal division after the Cold War
and the
statesman who believed in the
power
of international cooperation.
I was privileged to meet him on
several occasions up in Maine
and I could appreciate what a
kind, generous, and noble man he
was.
So tonight, tonight is December
4th.
It's actually an important date
for a particular reason that I
will not mention to you now.
You'll have to wait until the
end of my remarks.  And you're
not allowed to look at your cell
phone please.
[Laughter]
No.
I have to confess something
here.
When I walked into the  Great
Hall and
was given a lovely private tour
by you, Dr. Dr.
Hayden, three thoughts crossed
my mind.
The first one was this young
French
student who was studying for her
political sciences dissertation
back 42 years ago and spent time
in the reading room.  Thanks to
the Library of Congress I was
able to better research the work
I
did on Ralph Nader and the
American consumerism in those
days.  Thank you.  I'm in your
debt.
The second person I thought
about was my son, a young
architect.  He would love this
place.  He would love it.
The space, the height, the
creativity.
And the third thought I had was
about my country, France.  And
maybe another country, actually,
that I was just visiting a
couple of
days ago, Argentina.
Why is that?
Well, when this structure was
completed,
in 1897, the chief engineer
remarked, I
quote, that the Palagonia, the
Paris opera house, was the prime
suggestion for the new Library
of Congress.
That makes sense because the
Paris opera
house was completed 20 years
earlier in 1875.
Now, I think the French may have
borrowed a little bit from
others,
because Tiat Cologne in buenos
Eros was
finished in 1857.  If you look
at these two buildings, it tells
you something.
First of all, intellectual
property was of great interest
across borders, even back then,
attitude least among architects,
who happily borrowed from each
other, learned from each other,
and became inspired as a result.
Second, it reminds us that they
understood that building
something
lasting means linking the solid
foundations of the past with a
spark of imagination.
You can't just copy-cat.
That kind of creativity and
long-term vision rooted in
history and informed by our
successes and failures from the
past
is my theme for this evening.
First, where have we been?
How has creativity and
international economy
cooperation helped bring more
prosperity and more peace in the
world?
And second, where can we travel
together?
How can creativity and informed
visionary thinking help adopt
the international system to our
current challenges?
So let me begin first with a
little bit
of shared history, between the
International Monetary Fund and
the
United States of the last 75
years.
In the first half of the 20th
century,
the dominant economic and
military powers used force to
assert their self-interest at
enormous cost in terms
of human life and physical
destruction.
The tragic result compelled
nations to find a better way.
It only took them two wars, and
atrocities along the way, but in
1944, they found it.
The United States emerged as the
major global power and did
something unprecedented.
Informed by the devastateing
ultimate
outcome of of the
Versailles treaty which we just
celebrated the 100 year an
versesy, the
United States decided to go
forward with cooperation.  Dr.
Kissinger called the innovations
of the postwar period, I quote,
a great birth of creativity that
brought security to the world.
How did the U.S. do it?
Out of generosity?  Yeah.
With consideration to their
self-interest?  Yes.
And with a little help from some
of their friends.
Let us look at that turning
point of 75 years ago.
And think first of the creation
of the system itself.
The
Principal architect, John Kains
of the
UK and Harry Dexter White from
the U.S.
were deeply influenced by the
two wars.
They witnessed where there were
witnessed relationships that had
foundations in the treaty of
Versailles.
The result was imploding world
trade that deepened the
depression and caused massive
economic and social upheaval.
Ultimately, these pressures gave
rise
to nationalist and pop list
movement
ul populist movements and
eventually catastrophe.
Emerging from the second World
war, the U.S.
and some 40 countries gathered
in New Hampshire and decided to
create the International
Monetary Fund and the World
Bank.
They tasked the fund with
promoting
international monetary
cooperation, supporting trade
and economic growth, and
discouraging policies that would
harm prosperity.
It was revolutionary.  It was
visionary.  And guess what?
It worked.
From the very beginning, the IMF
helped
countries address major new
challenges through
collaboration.
Complimenting the  Marshall plan
we at
IMF helped Europe rebuild from
from the horror of war.
We helped to implement policies
to promote growth.  It's a
mission we continue to this day.
As you may have recently seen in
countries like arg Argentina,
Egypt, Ukraine, and many others.
The genius of this collaborated
system they invented was it was
designed to adapt and change.
And in the early '70s, that
change arrived.
Some of you might remember that
speech,
a land mark speech, the
challenge of peace.
President Nixon suspended the
U.S. dollar currency into gold
and that
shocked the world and forced a
year-long negotiation that led
to the modern
floating exchange rate
structure, away
from the fixed gold reference
structure, moving into floating
exchange rate structure.
System that is still today in
place, in many corners of the
world.
But at the time, some thought
that this particular change
would mean the end of the IMF.
But all our members at the time,
including the United States,
knew that the goal of stability
and prosperity extended well
beyond fixed exchange rates.
They recognized the benefits of
the
global financial firefighter
that could help countries in
times of need.
They built on what worked,
changed what
did not, and they adapted.
And we moved on.
1973, the oil crisis, the IMF
created
new tools, to help countries
facing an energy emergency in
line with the funds rule to help
smooth shocks and prevent
harmful spillovers.
As the debt crisis hit Latin
America in the '80s, the IMF
with creativity ideas and
support from the United States
stepped in to calm the waters.
After the fall of the Berlin
wall we took on a new challenge
which was
happening the Soviet Union  bloc
nations to transform themselves
from centrally planned to free
market economies.
In the 1990s
, the fund assisted countries in
overcoming first the Mexican
financial crisis and then the
Asian financial  crisis.
Throughout all these challenges,
we continued to help countries
throughout
the world with their
fundamentals, their fiscal and
monetary exchange rate policies
and with steps to build stronger
economic institutions.
Because without that
macroeconomic stability, growth
cannot prosper.
These efforts enabled better
policies
that opened markets, boosted
trade,
created jobs, and unleashed
economic potential.
And then came 2008, and the
financial crisis, the global
financial crisis.
Most of the other crises that I
have referred to applied to
particular regions.
This one was the first of a
completely global nature.  The
ensuing great recession reminded
us that international
cooperation was essential, not
optional.  As the French finance
minister at the time, I
certainly participated in that
exercise.
All G20 nations and the federal
reserve took trued extraordinary
steps to save the system.
Veterans, when we sort of come
together, we just wonder how we
did it,
and how much we transgressed and
had to
violate principles and rules and
reinvent.
But we helped secure the global
economy.
In the decade since the 2008
financial crisis, we supported
economic programs in 90
countries.
And adapted our lending
instruments,
including zero interest loans to
help low-income countries.
But the global economy did not
only need liquidity and
stimulus, it also needed to
reform its financial
architecture.  And we worked
with our membership to
build a stronger financial
sector so that we could,
together, limit the
consequences of what will be,
one day, the next crisis.
So we learned from the past.  We
got creativity.  And we changed
for the better.
And none of that, none of that,
would have been possible without
the United States.
This country challenged the
international quarter when it
needed challenging.  It forged
compromise when compromise was
necessary.  Why?  Why did it do
all that?  Benevolence?
It did so because a stronger and
more stable world paid dividends
for the United States.  It
enabled the U.S.
to enjoy some of the longest
runs of sustained economic
growth the modern world has ever
known.
Since that meeting in
Britainwoods
nearly 75 years ago, real U.S.
GDP increased by a factor of
eight.
The average American's real
income has quadrupled.
This did not come at the expense
of other nations.  On the
contrary, this country's
leadership paid the way not for
decades of opportunities here in
America, but
also growth that spread across
the world.
Now, today, that landscape is
shifting again.
And part of this change is
driven by geo politics, and the
shift in some economic power
from West to East.
Part of it by the rise of
non-state
actors, including multinational
organizations and corporates.
Part of it is driven by
technology,
and the rapid
acceleration of everything in
our lives.
As I'm sure you know, Dr.
Hayden, 90% of the world's data
was created just over the last
two years.
Now, I have to say as a daughter
of two
classics professors, I know my
parents would have found that
very, very depressing.
[Laughter]
But the truth is that everything
moves faster.  Information,
money, disease, you name it.
And these transformations can
bring enormous opportunities but
can also create massive risks.
Why is that?
Because more than ever before,
at least as was demonstrated in
2008, what
happens in one nation is going
to impact all nations.
From weapons of mass destruction
to cyber security to the
interconnected financial system,
many of our current challenges
recognize no borders.
So when support for
international cooperation
falters, we must remember
the lessons the United States
and her allies taught the world
over the last 75 years.  It's a
big lesson.
Solidarity is self-interest.
And that principle endures in
our changing world.  Our
challenge now is to yet again
adapt and reform.
So I believe that this year,
2019, can be another turning
point in our journey.
A moment when the world delivers
a new
burst of creativity in solving
our shared challenges.
There's something there which
you can't see but from which we
can draw inspiration.  Correct
me if I'm wrong, but it's
something like, they build too
low those who build beneath the
stars.  It's written up there.
Imagine what the world could be
if we
were to build beneath the stars,
the
docks as I call it, or the age
of anger.  Let's imagine.
The age of anger.
By 2040, inequality could exceed
the levels of the gilded age.
Strong monopolies and weak
governments
with ineffective domestic
policies could
make it impossible for startups
and entrepreneurs to succeed.
Health breakthroughs could allow
the richest to live past 120,
while millions
of others would suffer from
disease.
Social media would bombard
populations, underscoring the
difference between their reality
and the possibility of a better
life.
And the
aspiration gap would fuel
anxiety and anger.
Trust would break down.  The
world would be more connected
digitally, but less connected
every other way.
International cooperation for
the benefit of all would be a
concept best
studied in libraries like this
one, but rarely practiced on the
world stage.
Due to the supremacy of national
interest and a singular focus on
domestic policies.
So borrow from Dr.
Kissinger's world order, we
might be, I quote, facing a
period in which forces beyond
the restraints of any order
determine the future.
That is a very dystopian
scenario.
Isn't it?
Not one that we designed, and
certainly
not one that I believe can be or
should be our destiny.  Neither
does  Dr. Kissinger for that
matter.
We have overcome
existential threats before and
we can do so again.
Think of 2019, if we make it the
start of a different kind of AI.
Everybody thinks, oh, she's
going to talk about artificial
intelligence.  No.
Age of
ingenuity.
This would be a future fueled by
ingenuity and cooperation.
2040, I'm in a new scenario now.
We would see flourishing
economies
redominantly running on
renewable energy.
Women would be fully empowered
in the workforce proven to be an
economic game changer.  Health
care portability would reflect
the changing nature of work in
the digital economy.
Corporation would embrace social
responsibility as part of their
business model because they
would be rated on that, as well.
We could save lives and millions
of jobs.  We could see an end to
mass immigration and
peacefulness between nations
would prevail.
Am I being too optimistic?  Of
course!
You know the difference between
the
optimist and the pessimist?
They're both wrong, but the
optimist is happier.
[Laughter]
So I have to be optimistic.
Because I'm thinking about the
world my grandchildren will
inherit.
But it presents us with a
fundamental choice: Stand still
and watch discord
and discontent bubble over into
conflict conflict, or move
forward, reimagine the way
nations work together, and build
prosperity and peace.
Okay.  Nice words.  What does it
mean in practice?  It means
countries working together,
to put people, all people, at
the center of all our efforts.
Focusing on real results to
improve their lives.
It also means governments and
institutions being more
transparent and
accountable which includes
listening to more diverse
voices.  It means ensuring the
economic benefits of
globalizations are shared by
many, not just a few.
I call that the new
multilateralism.
You might just call it common
sense if that word suits you
better.
But let me be very clear here.
Good international cooperation
is
never going to substitute for
good domestic policy.  Of
course, individual countries
have the responsibility for the
well-being of their citizens.
In fact, strong domestic
policies can form the foundation
for effective
international cooperation, and
in our modern world there are
some issues that
can only be addressed through
international cooperation.
I want to discuss four such
issues.  I promise I'll be brief
on each of the four.
But I think they are all
important.
And to be successful in
delivering on
those four, we will need
creativity and we will need
cooperation.
Let me start with those, the
first one.  First one is trade.
I've been saying for some time
now that we need to fix the
system.  More recently, I've
been urging
countries to actually deescalate
trade tensions and it was
encouraging to see over the
weekend some progress made at
the G20 meeting in Buenos Ere
Aires.
We must continue the
deescalation and
improving trade for the future.
It means agreement and also
perfecting
intellectual property rights
without
stifling innovation and getting
rid of economic rents.
New trade agreements would
release the potential of
e-customers and trade
in-services.  All of this is
critical not for the
sake of trade, although Montes
que would argue with me.  He
would say where there is trade,
there is good manners.  He's
right.
Montesque is always right.
No, it's critical because trade
gives opportunity and
accelerates innovation, and we
need both.
Secondly, we need international
taxation cooperation.
Companies now have world-wide
presence.  Even when they're
small.
In the old days, you had to be
one of those top guns to be
international.
Now, very small companies can be
very international companies,
but governments
have not figured yet a
world-wide answer to tax.
And right now, too many tax
dollars are
left on the table, thanks to tax
optimization and the bad kind of
creativity.
So countries need to work
closely
together to collect what is
owed, where
it's owed, and avoid a race tax
to the bottom.
They can close the loopholes
that leads to base erosion and
profit shifting.
We are working with our partners
so
that they can share best
practices and revise regulation
for a digital economy in which
many companies have no single
established base of operation,
and yet they do operate.
Why do we need this?  Why do we
need revenue?  Because all
countries should be investing in
their future.  And public and
private funding working
together can strengthen
infrastructure, improve
education, and prepare all of us
to adjust to the technical
transformations of our
doorsteps.  When the return on
those investments are so far
away, it's unlikely the private
sector alone will actually
invest.
My third issue is our climate.
From the recent major hurricanes
in
the Caribbeans to the wildfires
in California, so the Pacific,
the dangerous effects of climate
change are becoming more
tangible by the day.  New U.S.
government study shows the
economic
impact from climate change could
reduce
America's GDP in the coming
decades.
The collaborative agreement in
Paris
in 2015 is probably the best
toolbox we
have to start fixing the
planetary challenge and move to
a zero carbon economy.
It's also ideas I've tried to
highlight tonight.
Creativity, visionary thinking,
and a commitment to the global
good that serves our best
interests.
This is for the survival of
future generations.
Now I mentioned three issues:
Trade, tax, climate.
Each of them is worthy of their
own Kissinger Lecture.
But there's one issue that I
believe is the bedrock for
progress nearly everywhere else.
And that is why the fourth and
final
area I want to discuss is good
governance, free from the
shackles of corruption.
The simple fact is that without
confidence in our institutions,
none of the change we seek will
be possible.  So let me focus on
that briefly.  It's my fourth
and last key  point.
Why is corruption so corrosive?
Because when people start
believing
the economy no longer works for
them, society no  longer works
for them, they start
disconnecting from economy and
disconnecting from society.
Corruption stops economy's
vitality
and siphons off desperately
needed resources.
Money diverted from education
and health habituates inequality
and limits the possibility of a
better life.
Do you know the annual cost of
bribery
alone -- and corruption is more
than just bribery -- but the
cost of bribery
is estimated to be at $1.5
trillion.
That's roughly 2% of global GDP.
Millennials feel the problem
acutely.
A recent survey of global youth
reveal that young people
identify corruption, not jobs,
not better education, but
corruption, as the most pressing
concern in their own countries.
There's wisdom in this insight
because corruption is the root
cause of many of the economic
injustices that many of these
young men and women are facing.
And that is why, with the
support of our
entire membership, we are going
to scrutinize anew the impact on
corruption on a country's
macroeconomic health.
So far we've done quite a bit of
work on anti-money laundering
and combating terrorism.
We've done that with 110 of our
country members.  But it's only
a small part of the
wider work needed to promote
good governance.  Investing in
institution is indispensable,
and also to verify that
those institutions actually
deliver.
Because likewise, corruption
knows no border.
Think for a second how
Sentec is changing the economic
game.
New innovations can be used by
cyber
criminals to
funnel illicit financial flows
on a worldwide basis.
This is not one nation's problem
or within one nation's ability
to solve.  It needs
cross-border collaboration.
But it is fixable.
The same innovations that create
cross cross-border challenges
can also be used to help us
fight back, through biometrics,
block chain, and more.
We can find better ways to build
a better, safer system for the
long term.
Governments can and must work
with the
world's best engineers to build
stronger cyber security systems
to protect
people's bank accounts, their
well-being and even hotel
bookings.
This is common good we must
choose to support.
If we take -- if we take the
challenge of corruption as the
model of
cooperation that we can
actually implement, it can be a
model for the other topics that
I've mentioned.
It can be the sign that the
brotherhood
of man, as Cains called it, is
ready once again to meet the
call of history.
Except, by the way, at this
time, women will play a role.
[Laughter]
[Applause]
You should have seen the photo
of those
who created  Brednews in 1944.
44 men.  Full stop.
[Laughter]
So I think it's by doing that we
can start restoring trust, which
is probably
the most precious and most
in-demand commodity in our
society.  This is how we begin
to adapt once more and reimagine
that international cooperation
that we need.
New, before I conclude, we have
one more thing to do.
I began my remarks by mentioning
that December 4th was an
important date.  There's one
person who is not allowed to
answer that question.  That's
Mrs.
Harmon who is the president of
the Woodrow Wilson center.
Because on December 4th, 1918,
exactly 100 years ago to this
day, president Woodrow Wilson
set sale for France to help
negotiate what he hoped would be
a lasting peace.
He became the first U.S.
-- the first sitting U.S.
president to travel to Europe.
And in some way, some ways, we
can trace
the origins of modern creativity
and visionary thinking in U.S.
foreign policy to this date.
It's also a humbling reminder
that our
plans do not always work out as
intended.  But it is also a
signal that we must try and try
and try again.  We must build on
what worked, change
what does not, and continually
evolve, improve, imagine a
better future for all people.
It was the vision that inspired
the
leaders of this country, and it
must be the mission that will
guide us in the days ahead.
Thank you very much.
[Applause]
>> Thank you, Madam Lagarde.
And without further delay, I
want to welcome to the stage,
please join me in
welcoming to the stage, Margaret
Brennan, moderator of CBS Face
the Nation.
[Applause]
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: Thanks to
all of you.
What a gorgeous venue to have
this conversation.
And I'm privileged to have it
today.
You know, at your introduction,
it was
pointed out you were named one
of the
third most powerful, I believe,
between
Theresa May and chancellor
Merkell in terms of the most
powerful women.
I think the correction needs to
be made you're actually one of
the most powerful individuals in
the world through the work
you've done to stabilize the
world economy.
That's why I think you laying
out your vision as you have,
there's a lot of things we want
to break apart here.
Let's start off with what's
happening today.
You're seeing recession fears
come out once again.  It was a
bad day in the market.  There
are some who looked at what
happened at the G20 and said
there wasn't progress.  You said
you saw some.  How do you define
some progress.  Where is the
hope you're seeing?
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: Well, I
might be
a little bit bias because I was
attending the G7 leaderring
meeting in
Canada and the
APEC meeting in paw paw new
genie.
And the APAC meeting there was
no communicatetion.  People
could not agree on anything.  So
the fact that leaders agreed on
a
set of  principles, issues,
points, the
fact that there was that, was in
a way reassuring.
So that's -- not a new
agreement.  I think it was
probably not as strong as some
expected it, but it really
touched on many critical issues.
The language was not exactly
according
to sort of the history of
communicay drafting.
There was clearly a consensus
trade was critically important.
Trade had to be conducted
according to
rules set by an institution, the
WTO,
that had to be reformed.  There
was clear agreement on the
principles of reform.  How it's
going to be reformed is another
matter and it's not going to
take a few weeks but probably
more months than weeks.
And there was willingness to
engage on the part of all.
And part of the night was not
such a bad outcome.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: You mean
in the
meeting between  Xi Peng and the
president?
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: Yes.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: Is 90 days
enough
to come to an agreement between
the two largest economies in the
world?
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: I'm not
sure the objective is a trade
agreement, but at least there's
a framework under which they
agreed to move forward and to
address some of the key issues.
You know, I think what's clearly
important is to come to an
understanding on both sides.  To
agree on some key principles.
To have definitions of what is a
subsidy, what warrants
intellectual property right
protection, and what is
the state on enterprise, and so
on and so forth.
So it is complicated and it is
going to take time.  But the
willingness of these two
presidents to move forward, and
to agree to discuss those
issues, I think is, compared
with what we have just gone
through, is progress.  Yes.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: And the
nervousness we're seeing in the
markets, you're saying, look,
they're talking.
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
We can't just react on a daily
market variation.  These things
take time.
Markets get jittery and react
sort of
off the cuff on the news of the
day, but I think those are, you
know, much longer-term issues
that warrant time,
thinking, considerations, and,
you know, it's also a clear
shift that we are
seeing and which is being
acknowledged
and will turn into, I hope, some
resolution.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: I think it
was, in listening to you sketch
out going back
to Brettenwood to the president,
I think it's a good reminder to
many people that the U.S.
was part in parcel of creating
many of these international
institutions, because now in our
daily political life, they're
described or at least felt or
perceived by some to be against
U.S. interest.
That is how some of the more
popularist rhetoric has
described institutions like
yours.
Today, Mike Pompeyo listed what
he felt
were all the flaws of
international or organizations
and even the IMF failed
to live up to what it was meant
to do,
which was rebuild Europe.  That
these measures are actually
hurting the world, not helping
it.  What do you make of his
speech?
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: First of
all, I
did not read his entire speech.
Bits and pieces were picked up.
I will very carefully read his
speech.
I've heard this austerity
comment made in many instances.
When we are called upon to help
a
country that is in very dear
financial difficulty, we have to
restore stability.
We have to restore public
finance discipline discipline.
We have to empower the
authorities with financing.
That's one thing we do.
But we are also an instrument of
macroeconomic sanity.
If we're called upon to act,
because there was mismanagement,
there was poor
public finance organizations,
there was poor monetary policy,
for multiple reasons, the
situation was not in order.  And
we're trying not to bring
austerity, but to bring order.
So that's number one.
Number two, if we did not come
in to help, the situation would
be even worse.  Because what
happens is when a country
calls for help, we come in, we
do expect
that public finances will be,
you know, redisciplined,
reorganized, and that stability
will result, at which point
investors come in
and say, okay, now the situation
is standardized.  We can come
back and we can invest.
If we did not do that, they
simply would not come in at that
point.
So I think it's -- we're not the
merchant of austerity, per se.
We are merchant of trust in the
stability of a system that is
needed in order to attract
investors, generate
growth, and, you know, entail
creation of jobs.
We are the enablers of that.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: You called
out for a kind of collaborative
leadership.  Particularly from
the United States.
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: Because
that is what has worked.  When I
look back and consider the
history of the United States'
role, its
involvement, what has worked,
how it has worked for this
country and others, that
collaboration has proven
extremely efficient.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: Well, the
secretary of state today said
the administration is working to
refocus the
IMF, and WTO, to promote more
prosperity, into nations that
can
already access global capital
markets, and to banks that could
raise capital on their own.
That's his vision that he
describes what the U.S. should
be implementing right now.
What do you make of that
proposal?
It was delivered in  Brussells
and it ruffled a few feathers.
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: Making
sure that capital can invest,
that's exactly what we do.
It's because private capital has
completely lost interest in
certain countries.
When I look at the three I
mentioned: Egypt, Ukraine,
Argentina.  Why did they come
in?  Nobody else wanted to come
in.  There was not a single
investor prepared to take the
risk of going in
because the situation was in
disorder,
public finance was not properly
managed, and there was internal
factors that created massive
instability.
So we come in and enable the
country to become attractive
again.  It's not as if we were a
substitute to
private sector investors,
investment.
We are the facilitators of that
Otherwise, they simply won't
come.  Too risky for them.  Once
they know we're involved, they
know we put in place
sustainability.  If
restructuring is needed, we ask
for it.  If new monetary policy
needs to be
implemented, we recommend it,
and it's
implemented, with some success,
I dare say.
I'm not sure he understands very
clearly what is -- what is --
well, our mission is prosperity.
Yes.
This is what the initial
founders actually tasked us to
do.  That's what we need to do.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: So these
descriptions of the vision and
the leadership that America is
providing on
this front, for you it is not
achieving
what you were saying is needed,
to meet the crises right now
that you see?
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: I was
curious
about the  taxpayers' money.
We've actually always paid back
and more.  So over the course of
time, the United States has
actually made quite a bit of
money out of the IMF involvement
in countries.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: You think
there's
a fundamental misunderstanding
or are
there portions of truth to these
criticisms?
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: Well the
fact that growth must be
generated as a
result of our involvement is
something I  completely agree
with.  It doesn't come overnight
because you
need to restore the situation
and start public finance and
reorganize sometimes
through structural reforms of
the economy, but growth
ultimately comes.
I'll tell you.
As French finance minister we
had to deal with some difficult
cases in Europe.
But when I look at a country
like port gal, the involvement
of the IMF was critical in
turning the situation around,
sorting out quite a few
difficult issues.
Portugal is now doing pretty
well compared with other
European countries.
When I look at Ireland, it's
thriving.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: Those are
countries that needed help in
crises?
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: We had to
come in with the IMF and put in
place significant lending
programs and we
expected serious measures to be
taken on the fiscal front,
because there was too much
fiscal deficit, and in the case
of Ireland because the banking
system was
completely out of control, and
had gone way too far into
extending beyond the country.
So this -- these programs have
clearly generated a growth.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: When you
use that phrase, you know,
describing we could
live in an age of anger, putting
a time line out decades from
now, if you look
at some of the forces, not just
in the United States, but
contributed to making trade a
very contentious issue during
the 2016 campaign on the left
and on the right, but also what
you're seeing in
Europe, in your home country of
France right now protests around
the economy, and specifically
the gas tax.
I won't get into president
trump's tweet about it tonight.
But generally speaking, aren't
you seeing those forces of
anger?
I mean you're seeing more
populist governments come to
power, or at least
with the economy,
anti-multilateral institutional
rhetoric, in a lot of places
right now.
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: Yeah.
That is correct.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: Are we in
that time you're describing?
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: We are at
risk of
slipping into that kind of age
of anger, which is why it's
critically important to actually
address those issues.  As I was
trying to explain in my remarks,
those are not issues that can be
addressed purely domestically.
Some of them have to be
addressed domestically, but when
it comes to
trade, to tax, to climate
change, to cyber security, to
corruption, it has to
be on an international
cooperation basis, as well.
They come together.  But yes.
There has to be a response to
those
issues, because many people are
not satisfied with the income,
not satisfied with their future,
have this anxiety of what the
future holds for their children,
and all these concerns need to
be addressed.
And need to be addressed by
societies at large.
>> Margaret: The challenge is
the lack of trust in the
institutions that have been
tasked with this.
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: Yes.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: You
mentioned your time as minister
of finance in France.  Clearly,
one of the difficult time
periods you could have that job.
I remember from covering it that
same
famous story of you speaking to
frank Paulson and advising him
against
allowing Lehman brothers go
under.
You foresaw the domino effect.
Did you draw a line between what
you predicted then and where we
are now?  Is that where this
shift began that you're laying
out?
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: I
certainly did not anticipate
that at the time.  But looking
back, yes, I think that there's
a lot in today's anger,
resentment, frustration, that is
actually attributable to the
legacy of the crisis.
I think that we did a reasonably
good job in trying to strengthen
the financial  system, avoid
that people actually lose all
their savings, and that they be
bankrupt all over those
countries.
But I think the fact that we
addressed the issues of
institutions of the financial
system at large, without doing
probably enough explanation as
what it
meant for people, and the fact
that many
involved in those -- in those
financial
deals got away with it and
managed to reestablish
themselves, I think created a
sense of impunity.  In other
words, some of the lower
middle-class people thinking to
themselves, "Okay, I've lost my
job.  I've lost my house.  And
those people, what have they
lost?  Their bonus?  Yeah.  But
that's about it."
And they reestablished
themselves.
So I think this is not at the
root of and the only component
of the frustration and the anger
that we see,
but it's certainly participating
and fueling it.  That's what I
call the sort of untold story of
the legacy of the crisis.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: So how do
you address that?
If that age of anger is
simmering?
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: I think,
you know, in a way it's too late
to go back
to things that should have taken
place at that time, but we also
have the possibility with new
technologies, digital age, that
is clearly in the
making at the moment, and at an
accelerated pace, to organize it
in such a way it's transparent
and accountable
and it includes people, that
they're
plugged into that digital
picture by being properly
trained, educated, and
skilled, and they don't feel
there's emass collation that you
have when
something is so out of it to you
and foreign to you that you feel
that anger about it.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: You want
another
Bretten woods type summit.
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: There are
so many
groups who want another
Brettenwood?
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: Who leads
this?
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: Multiple
leaders everywhere.  They don't
have to give advice and draft
the programs and provide
technical assistance around the
world to 189 countries.  But,
you know, the beauty of the
institution that I have the
privilege to
lead is that in its articles, in
its
foundations, are the seeds for
constant transformation.
What is changing massively
around it
calls for probably a different
approach.  I think the digital
economy in which
we are moving, which is
transforming the
financial sector, which is
transforming
the existing relationship
between value
and monetary costs, all that
needs new thinking.  I think
it's more new thinking than a
reform of the Brettenwood
system.
>> I know the IMF has written
on this and talked about the
demand for cash.  And money
itself is changing.  Not just
how we think and talk about
this.
You mentioned Sintec in that
context, financial technologies,
and all the various forms of
it.
I mean there are advantages and
disadvantages, these days it
seems to be not very well
understood, even by the public
at large.  How much more of this
needs to be led not by the IMF
or these organizations but
coming from the corporate world,
coming from silicon valley.
You have these hearings on
capitol hill and the joke is you
have CFO's coming up and the
individuals asking them don't
even know how to use the
websites that they're talking
about.  How do you regulate
crypto currencies.  How do you
talk about all of this in a way
that actually leads to some kind
of regulation or reform?
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: Well,
first of all, I don't think it
should be entirely
left in the lands of hands of
those corporate sector
representatives or
their legal departments, because
they're
dealing with common good and
your privacy and their data and
they're
dealing with your freedom.
So governmental authorities,
parliamentarians, have to be
involved.  And they have to be
helped along the
way for those who are not
computer literate, those who
feel completely
alien to these digital
transformations, they have to be
helped by people like
us, at IMF, with financial
technologies,
because we try to grasp what it
means, how it is formed, how
those technologies
are used to shorten the
circuits, to
enable payments, and to include
people
that we're were not included in
the banking sector, for
instance.
So it is a public
responsibility.  And it has to
be done, again, in cooperation
with those engineers, in
cooperation with those who
understand the future of data
protection, who understand, you
know, how Cloud will
eventually, you know, be
antibioticsible
accessible or hackable.
So there are many technologies
that you don't master and I
don't, either, but
having enough knowledge to
understand
the key principles that need to
be
respected, it's on the shoulders
of the parliamenttarians and the
governments because they today
have the responsibility to
represent the people.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: You've
also answered the call for a lot
of parliamenttarians to get rid
of the
legal obstacles to the inclusion
of women in the economy.  Where
does that begin?
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: Very
often it begins at home.
About 90% of the countries in
the
institution still have in their
constitution or in the legal
system
discrimination against  women,
barriers to their participation
in the economy,
to in inheritance
when parents die, to owning a
business, to their opening a
bank account, so
being able to bring calculates
when they try to have a loan.  I
think that's where the work has
to begin.  We've demonstrated or
observed in many
countries, such as some Latin
America
countries like Peru and some
African countries, as well, that
when those
changes happen, it actually has
consequences on the economy and
pushes growth and enables women
to become better integrated into
the economy.  But it's not only
that.
It begins there because there
should not be legal barriers and
legal
constraints imposed by
governments that prevent women
from playing their role in the
economy.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: How much
of an economic benefit is there?
How do you quantify?
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: Huge.
It's huge.  It varies.
If you look at the Nordic
countries,
you know, norway being clearly
one of
the best performers, finland
being very good, as well.
From those countries, to say,
India or Saudi Arabia, you can
have an increase
in the economy which varies from
3% to 27%.  That's nothing to be
turning your eyes away.  It's
pretty big.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: Why the
resistance?
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: Ha.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: If you can
make
the argument on  numbers, why
the resistance?
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: I think
you're talking about something
that goes much, much deeper into
culture, into psyche, into the
way in which societies have been
built over the course of time.
You are also talking about the
divide
between urban centers and rural
areas.  You know?  India is a
case in point where clearly
in rural areas, in particular,
women are
prevented from joining the flow,
from being economic partners,
and sometimes
from accessing sanitation.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: Bigger
picture, because we're running
out of time, I'd
be remiss if I didn't ask you
about Brexit, and the forces
sort of pulling at the global
order right now.
That's a rejection of
international organizations and
solidarity there.  Add that in
to what you're seeing here in
the U.S., as well, in terms of
that kind of rejection.
It sounds like you're trying to
swim upstream.
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: One,
first of all, I think the
situation has changed.  And is
changing in the US.  When I look
at the latest poll
produced, the shift is now into
a majority of those polled.
You can term polls in which ever
way you
want, but it seems there are
more Brits who would rather
remain than exit.  Number one.
Number two, I think a lot of the
campaign that took place at the
time,
two years ago now, was geared
towards, "Watch out.
The foreigners are going to take
your
meal away, and they're going to
have -- they're going to go
first in the health benefit and
health care system and
they're going to take jobs," and
it was
the fear of the foreigners.  And
unfortunately from within
Europe.
And it was directed at people
from Poland, Bulgaria and
Romania, who, by the way, have
been extremely well
integrated  in, say, the German
economy, as was demonstrated
recently, in a country that
needed additional skilled labor.
So that fear factor that was
raised
during the campaign may have
completely
missed the opportunity that that
particular flow of migration
actually
produced in an economy nextdoor,
which was Germany.
So that's a little bit beside
the point.
But I think there is regret in
many, many European corners.
I think there is more regret in
the UK than there were only six
months ago.
And I think there is now the
realization that there will be
more loss
as a result of Brexit than was
ever
mentioned, described, accounted
for, by those who campaigned for
the  Brexit.
I can say that with relative
confidence,
because when we produced the
article 4
for the UK, which was the annual
audit
we do of all economies, we did
actually
give -- we did give at the time
three scenarios of Brexit.
One of which was the baseline
which was pretty much in line
with what everybody assumed, but
another one which was a dark
scenario which is very close to
some of the numbers we're seeing
now.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: The dark
scenario?
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: In terms
of forecast coming up in case of
a Brexit development and in case
of a no-deal
Brexit, which is what we had
considered.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: Is that a
warning to brace ourselves?
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: I think
it was a very clear, you know,
assessment of what
the consequences would be as a
result of a  no-deal Brexit
scenario, where the
terms of trade between the UK
and its main economic and trade
partner, which
is the European union, would be
done
under the WTO rules with no
additional sweetener to WTO
rules.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: The dark
scenario is a scary phrase to
end on, but unfortunately I'm
told that we are --
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: No, there
was
something interesting today,
.  For those like me who would
like to
keep the UK within the European
union there is a perfectly
acceptable and legal way to
revoke the article 50, which was
the provision under which the UK
pulled out.
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: You think
it's a viable scenario?
>> CHRISTINE LAGARDE: At least
it's legal.
[Laughter]
>> MARGARET BRENNAN: I think
this is
the optimist you destroyed
yourself described yourself
before.  I'm sure a number of
people would like to continue
that conversation with you
offline, but I know we have to
finish.  Thank you, madam
Christine Lagarde.
And thanks to all of you.
[Applause]
>> Well, the next move is up
the stairs
to your left, and dinner will be
served
and you'll get your table
assignments up there.
[End
event at 7:52 p.m.
E
T.]